- So, basically, they're a woven material
with adhesive and polymer.
And when you wet it,
it attaches to the skin
and you leave it on for
five to 10 minutes usually.
And when you pull it off,
you'll see sort of these like
stalagmite, stalactite
type things on the strip
and that's actually oil from your skin
that gets oxidized and
turns black in color
as well as bacteria,
dead skin, hair, dirt,
basically anything that's on the surface
just gets pulled off.
A deep cleansing doesn't
happen with these strips.
Although your skin may
feel cleaner, smoother,
they really don't do anything
to prevent you from developing blackheads.
I totally get that they're satisfying,
but I don't think over
long periods of time,
they do much for you.
Other things should be used.
Retinoids and retinols and chemical peels
can all be used in
conjunction with pore strips.
Some people are worried that
they can break capillaries.
Very rarely can it
cause significant damage
although I do see patients all the time
with lots of irritation,
particularly if they're
using it frequently.
Using pore strips responsibly
is really important.
You don't want to use them
more than once a week.
You want to make sure your skin is clean
before you use them.
You want to follow the directions.
Don't leave them on for
longer than they say.
Always remove the adhesive
to prevent irritation.
And cleanse your face after.
People who have allergies to
different cosmetic products
should just be a little bit careful.
Sometimes I'll tell people to
put them on their arms first
just to make sure that
they aren't sensitive
and then put them on the face.
Although I really don't tell patients
to use them necessarily,
if people like them, I'm not
telling people not to use them.
I mean, I totally get it, they're fun.
I use them too sometimes.